[Music]
welcome to the science podcast for
February 9th 2018 I'm Sara Krusty in
this week's show David Grimm discusses
lab animal happiness
what if standardizing lab animals
environment has made them less useful
for science should we enrich the lives
of zebrafish
rats rabbits mice so that they're more
like people and John Abbott is here to
talk about indoor chemistry even though
some of us spend 90% of our time indoors
it turns out we don't understand much
about the chemistry of the environment
inside buildings now we have David Grimm
editor for our daily news site he's here
to talk about his recent feature story
on lab animal happiness hi Dave hey sir
okay your future asked questions like
should we make lab animals happy how can
we tell if they're happy and what
happens if they are happy let's let's
talk about first why they might not be
so happy right now well happiness is a
very subjective term but what animal
facility managers and labs have focused
on in the past is wealth there are these
guys healthy do they seem healthy and
are they free of disease now that is
obviously not the same as happiness but
the reason advocates are starting to say
that maybe they're not happy is because
of the environments we put them in if
you walk into any university and look at
a standard Mouse cage you're gonna see a
shoebox size cage probably made out of
clear plexiglass it's probably got some
corncob like a little bedding material
on the bottom it's got a pile of food
and it's got a spigot for water and
that's pretty much yet same thing for
fish if you go into a fish lab you'd see
these tanks full of water with a bunch
of fish moving around maybe some food in
them and that is it so for decades we've
been keeping lab animals especially
rodents and fish he needs very kind of
bland very sterile and it's a good
reason I mean the idea is that it's the
same in my lab as it is in your lab
right so the idea is it's very good for
reproducibility because if a lab is
trying to repeat its own results or
trying to repeat the results of another
lab it wants things to be exactly the
same also scientists like to limit
variables they don't like a lot of
there's stuff interfering with their
experiments and they say well like if I
put a running wheel in the air if I put
toys in there that's going to interfere
with my experiment and I need these guys
to essentially be free test tubes they
need to be exactly the same from cage to
cage a lot a lab that sounds reasonable
but it turns out that this penchant for
reproducibility for kind of keeping
variability out of the lives of these
animals might actually make them not
such good test subjects well there's two
big problems in biomedical research
right now what is called the
reproducibility crisis and that is a lot
of labs are having trouble reproducing
other labs results and the other crisis
is the translate ability crisis only one
in nine drugs that work in animals ever
succeed in people and advocates for
improving the lives of lab animals are
starting to say well maybe it's the way
we treat them we don't treat these
animals anything like people if you had
a person and you put this person in a
plain white room with no furniture
nothing to do nothing to play with
nothing to entertain themselves all day
long and they sat there for years and
then you did experiments on them with
the results of those experiments have
anything to do with us with us as people
that live our lives we have challenges
we have stress we have things to play
with and entertain us and emotionally
and cognitively stimulate us and so what
they're saying is that the same for
animals because if you've got a mice
that lives in one of these barren cages
it's not anything like a mouse that
lives in the wild that's digging that's
burrowing that's got friends to play
with that's got challenges every day and
how is that showing up in their biology
I can imagine that maybe the mice are
crazy but are they also not as healthy
because of this well so you know lab
runs tend to be obese they have weak
immune systems and they are more prone
to develop cancer and this is before we
do any experiments on them how can we
tell that it's the way they're being
treated the way they're being housed
that is causing these problems what kind
of experiments are being done or how do
we know there's a connection there we
don't know that for sure but we know
that things like stress anxiety can have
an impact on immune systems if you've
got an animal that you're testing
psychiatric drugs on and in animals
really depressed because it sort of
lives by itself all day then those drugs
may be less likely to work or maybe they
weren't really
well and the animal but they don't
really work well in us because we're not
at the same baseline as this animal is
so we don't know for sure that these
environments are causing these problems
we know that things like stress
isolation depression not just any
animals but also in people can have
significant impacts on in biology and
physiology we're not just talking about
mice here or rodents we're talking about
fish and rabbits we're talking about
fish and rabbits the one animal that I
don't really talk about a lot of my
story is non-human primates and because
these animals actually do live in a
fairly what we call an enriched
environment they live thanks to changes
in guidelines both in the US and abroad
they live in environments where they
have a lot of companions often that they
get toys they get nesting material
chimpanzees get movies and music which I
didn't realize but again we're talking
about rodents and fish they don't get
that much stuff and so the story is
really about you know should we be
enriching the lives of these animals
should we be giving rats soil to dig in
like they have in the wild should we be
giving mice running wheels because we
know experience has shown that actually
like running on wheels I'll just sort of
run on wheels for the heck of it should
we be giving rabbits paper bags full of
crinkly paper so they can tear it apart
and kind of forge through it like they
would forage in the wild and there's a
group at the University of Michigan
there's a team called the real program
there's actually testing a lot of these
enrichment sandfish like multi colored
marbles deficient like marbles and their
tank does it remind them of maybe a the
bottom of a lake or a stream what kind
of results would they expect to see if
these enrichments were working so the
first thing they see is do the animals
actually like the enrichment so for the
fish you know they give a fish the
choice between kind of an empty side of
their tank and a tank maybe with a
plastic plant in it and where did the
fish spend more time with Rabbids - you
know rabbits don't like certain
enrichments because rabbits will pee on
sort of the bridge they add them but you
know say they had plastic keys for the
routes chew on
if the Roberts spend a lot of time
chewing on the keys and if they're much
more likely to sort of have a companion
in their cage and not fight with our
companion - you get along with that
companion if they have these plastic
keys to chew maybe this is an enrichment
that works so that's the first step what
enrichments actually do the animals like
do they like having in their cage and
the second step is to see do these
enrichments actually improve science
could they help
tres the reproducibility and the
translate ability crises is that someone
anyone has tried to answer so that's
what they're doing you know that's one
of the steps now is to figure out you
know do these things actually make a
difference for the science there is some
evidence that this stuff makes a
difference for example there was an
experiment done in 2000 with mice that
showed that mice that were given toys to
play with and mazes to run through were
much less likely to develop symptoms of
Huntington's like disease than mice that
lived in a very bare in standard caging
and in 2010 research was sort of very
similar thing with cancer in mice that
mice that had played in an environment
that had so many running wheels and you
know wood blocks and mazes and stuff
like that one of the researchers
daughters actually calls it Disneyland
for mice and mice that were actually
live in this environment where 80% less
likely to get certain types of cancers
than mice that live in standard caging
so we know enrichment can make a big
difference for the physiology of these
animals and the question is does it make
a big difference for scientific research
as a whole what about the pushback that
there's bound to be on this I mean how
can you standardize something that's
basically introducing fun into the lives
of animals all right and now we get back
to what we were talking about the
beginning is this going to not help but
actually exacerbate the reproducibility
crisis because you know if I'm using
plastic red balls with my mice in my lab
and you're using running wheels in your
lab how are we going to sort of
reconcile our two experiments and also
these enrichments are very resource
intensive
they can cost a lot of money or adding
extra things to the cage which have to
be bought you have to be cleaned that
could take a lot longer to clean cages
so so some critics are pushing back and
saying okay loud to actually afford to
do this we've done a lot of stories on
the podcast about how lab animals
they're affected by the gender of the
person handling them introducing them to
wild strains of mice changes their
microbiome and their immunity to
different diseases is the lesson here
really that variability is just going to
help in the long run with experiments
involving animals and that's the big
question you know I think what advocates
would say is what we're really learning
is that these animals are not free test
tubes and you can't treat them like an
inanimate object so you've got to
realize they're gonna respond an
interesting and complex ways in the
environment
around them and we really need to start
thinking a lot more about the
environment these animals live in okay
well what else is on the site this week
do we have any non animal stories days
okay
well Sarah we've got a story about the
science of silky healthy hair news you
can use also a story about an alien
solar system that may have seven earth
sized planets at least one of which
might have water on it for science and
said our policy blog we've got a story
about new environmental laws in Canada
also a story about a fight over a 1
billion dollar tobacco research fund so
be sure to check out all these stories
on the site thanks Dave thanks Sarah
David Grimm is the editor for our online
daily news site stay tuned for John
Abbott he's up next with insights into
chemistry that goes on inside of
buildings this week in science john
abbott and sasha ogla Gorsky right about
the indoor chemical cocktail and john is
here to tell us what we know about
pollution and chemistry inside of
buildings and what we don't welcome John
hello thanks for the invitation what do
you mean by indoor pollution in the
title of your article the topic of
indoor air has been has been looked at
for a while topics that have come up a
lot have been related to molecules that
get emitted from building materials or
from from the ground for example radon
comes in to basements of late in the
last you know a few years it's become
apparent that there are a lot of
reactive transformations sort of real
chemistry happening indoors and so in
addition to these sort of potentially
toxic sort of background materials that
come from building materials etc there
is also this transformation chemistry
going on that that we understand a lot
about in the outdoor environment but we
haven't been paying as much attention to
in the indoor environment you name a few
kind of known culprits in your story
things like bleach cigarettes cooking
stoves what what do we know that they're
doing in in the indoor environment and
and what kind of reactions are those
materials that they emit undergoing yeah
some of the chemistry can be quite
complex some can be quite simple so in
the case of bleach
we all know that it's not good to
breathe bleach or when you're when
you're washing surfaces with bleach the
warnings are appropriate to say it's not
good to to do this in a poorly
ventilated space but I don't think
people had looked at the detailed
processes that occur and as an example
it was found that if you wash a floor
for example with bleach most of the
chlorine that's in that bleach comes
into the gas phase in the form of
different molecules things called hepa
chlorous acid and chlorine gas and then
those chemicals can go on and do further
chemistry and so I think those details
were not so well understood and the same
goes true with cigarette smoke we know
we're not supposed to breathe it that it
can be harmful but some of the detailed
chemistry that it undergoes under indoor
environments has not been studied
previously what about things that you
know we hadn't thought were contributing
to the chemistry of the environment the
air but in particular in the indoors
what are some of the things that we
should be looking at my background is
more in the outdoor chemistry world but
in the last few years I've been doing
quite a bit at work indoors one of the
surprises to me was the role for example
the humans play human occupancy plays
and setting the the chemical state of
the indoor environment and and so an
oxidizing species an oxidant it's
commonly studied indoors as ozone and it
comes in largely from outdoors and so
you can have certain amounts of ozone in
an indoor space the amount that you have
will be dependent on how open your
windows are and how leaky your house is
if you then have that amount of ozone
and then you put people into that space
it turns out that the ozone is removed
to some degree and what's happening is
that the ozone is actually reacting on
us reacting with our surfaces and
producing chemicals we really hadn't
anticipated would be in indoor spaces
breathing ozone isn't great for you at
ground level it's not the best thing
it's an emission from cars but what
about inside our house is that something
we have to be concerned about are we
just observing its interaction with
people at this point some of this
chemistry is not necessarily bad I'm
entirely speculating here I have noise
but nothing to back this up but you know
it may be that our skin oils have
chemicals in them that do react with
ozone in order to
protect us against ozone and and so you
know that chemistry going on maybe
something that might actually be a good
thing it can produce molecules that are
potentially allergenic and so you know
some people may respond differently to
that chemistry than other people do one
thing you point about out up is how fast
these reactions are can you give us a
sense of the time scale for that yeah so
this is a really classic work that was
done by a couple of researchers this
taller and Wechsler who Illustrated that
if you put two people in two this was a
test chamber but rather like an indoor
room the ozone would drop by a factor of
1/2 on timescales of minutes to tens of
minutes and so the chemistry can be
really very fast another example is what
we emit even without chemistry occurring
for example in in crowded spaces like
classrooms some personal care products
have been observed to be the the highest
abundance chemicals in the gas phase so
if you can smell them there's chemistry
probably going on right that's exactly
the point you know we're bringing really
advanced new instrumentation indoors in
the last few years and we're learning
you know what is indoors and so it's a
little bit of an exploratory phase right
now right one interesting thing you
mentioned is lighting so light inside
tends not to have a lot of UV raining
down on us but outside the Sun emits in
the UV range and it affects the
chemistry in the air what are some of
the differences between indoor and
outdoor chemistry because of that change
and lighting I hadn't appreciated this
until I started working in this area as
how dark it is indoors it can be you
know hundred times maybe even a thousand
times darker inside and then it might be
outdoors on a sunny day and on top of
that the ultraviolet light can be
attenuated even more so you know indoors
it's a little bit like Twilight and the
chemistry that will proceed will be that
which doesn't need as energetic sunlight
you know the photons don't have that
happen as much energy in them you kind
of describe this cleaning process of the
air when it comes to sunlight and how
that might be something going on inside
but with a totally different mechanism
the outdoor environment is known to
be oxidising meaning that some of the
chemicals that we emit or planets emit
into the atmosphere get degraded through
this oxidation process that will go on
more slowly indoors because we don't
have as much ultraviolet light as you
said but it will still proceed and we're
trying to find out whether it proceeds
via the same pathways but more slowly or
via perhaps different pathways one area
that I'm interested in is the chemistry
that proceeds on surfaces indoors some
surfaces we wash very frequently like
kitchen countertops but others walls and
windows we may not wash as frequently at
all are those surfaces still pristine or
have they built up this sort of organic
like layer on them having been exposed
to molecules for months or years and
then upon exposure to ozone or to these
low levels of light what happens to them
should we think about this as pollution
does there have to be a degree of danger
to call something pollution or is it
we're making things dirty by living in
them and these are the things that we
need to think about because we're inside
so much yeah I'm hesitant necessarily
calling the whole field a pollution
field because much of the chemistry is
what we're accustomed to and we have
been accustomed to for a long time it is
certainly the case that in many
circumstances it can be more polluted
outside than inside but indoors you can
have a different types of compounds you
can have different types of organics
that build up that might have different
eventually potentially toxic effects a
very dramatic example of this for which
there are very serious health concerns
is cooking indoors in particular in the
developing world there can be a lot of
very inefficient use of aerion efficient
cookstoves with very poor ventilation
and that will release harmful chemicals
into the air
things like soot and polycyclic aromatic
hydrocarbons which are known to be can
be quite toxic and those can be in the
air but then they can also deposit onto
surfaces I think it's very clear that's
a form of pollution that has to be
addressed
yes and what about pollution from the
outside coming into the house or a
building I mean is that something that
will be detected in this kind of
research yes that's always an in
important reference state is to look at
what is outside because we know what's
outside is always coming inside to some
degree and so ozone again is a good
example it comes in from outdoors
nitrogen oxides sometimes come in from
outdoors particles as well and it all
very much depends on how leaky your
house is or your building site is you
know there's a tendency now to close our
windows to air-condition to make the
house houses quite tight to make them
more energy-efficient there's a
compromise there because your yo is true
you're restricting outdoor pollution
from coming in but you're also then
accentuating these indoor sources mm-hmm
so should we leave our doors open or
doors closed or windows open our windows
closed I mean that's a hard one - it
sounds like the jury's still out I think
the jury is still out the intention here
isn't to say there's chemicals there's
chemicals in your house chemicals are
bad it's more about a better
understanding of what's going on inside
and outside and how we can kind of
balance our control of things that might
be bad for us is that right that's
exactly right we just need to understand
fundamentally the chemistry that's
occurring indoors as a chemist I find it
a very intriguing space in which to work
and and there's a lot unknown here and
we can learn a lot by combining the
expertise that building engineers and
indoor air quality scientists have
developed over many years of working in
this field with some of the chemical
insights that have been learned in the
outdoor environment in the last few
years as well I interviewed someone a
very long time ago about microbes in the
built environment and how sampling them
has this new enterprise that has really
revealed a completely different way of
thinking about where we live you know
there were specific microbes that live
on electronics that were being found and
this really seems to follow up on those
same lines we've built something now we
actually need to use some science to
understand what what we've done you know
the lessons from some of the
microbiological work indoors that are
that you know humans have a large impact
and and I think that human occupancy is
also being shown to have a you know
very high-impact indoors not only
through our activities like cooking and
cleaning but also just from from being
ourselves indoors yeah
all right John thank you so much for
talking with me thank you no I
appreciate the chance to talk about this
topic John Abbott and Sascha bluegrass
key right about the indoor chemical
cocktail this week in science you can
find a link to their article at science
mad or gosh podcasts and that concludes
this edition of the science podcast if
you have any comments or suggestions for
the show write to us at science podcast
at AAAS dot o-r-g you can subscribe to
the show on iTunes stitcher and many
other places or listen to us on the
Science site at science math or podcast
where you can also find links to the
research and news stories discussed in
each episode the show was produced by
Sarah Crespi Jeffrey could compose the
music on behalf of science magazine and
as publisher triple-s
thanks for joining us